the 208 billion dollar-a-year hotel
industry is massively competitive
location branding and architecture are
all very important but in here is where
the competition gets particularly heated
hotel amenities pretty much everything
that's provided by hotels outside of the
room itself are an easy way for a hotel
to set themselves apart from the others
some amenities we come to take for
granted TV seems more like a minimal
requirement than an added feature at
this point some amenities seem obvious
but have never caught on
for some reason why are there three
different soaps and two kinds of lotions
but no toothpaste occasionally a chain
of hotels introduces an innovative
amenity and the other chains raced to
catch up and one-up each other creates
an intense period of amenity competition
let's look at some of the hotel
amenities wars throughout history and
see if maybe were in the midst of
another one right now the most recent
and intense amenity war centered around
bedding it started in 1999 when
Starwood's Weston introduced the
heavenly bed the floral print bed
spreads were replaced with white on
white bedding by Simmons with a
pillowtop mattress containing 900 coils
three sheets and a Down blanket
available in three different thicknesses
depending on your climate the move to
white on white bedding actually caused
the cleanliness scores for hotels to go
up not only did things look cleaner but
the hotels were actually forced to wash
the bedding more frequently since the
white bedding didn't hide dirt and
stains as well as the darker floral
patterns
pyat was not to be left behind they
fired back with the Grande bed a Sealy
Posturepedic mattress with down blankets
at 250 thread count triple
and none of this was cheap mariette
spent 190 million to upgrade beds at its
family of hotels each king-size bed at
Marriott featured 300 thread count
cotton sheets 7 pillows a fluffy
mattress cover and a white duvet each
chain and turn introduced their own take
on luxurious bedding the battle
culminating with the Pan Pacific
Vancouver installing $10,000
british-made hypnose duchess mattresses
but the war wouldn't end there it would
move to the bathroom before settling
down for a while
Weston spending over ten million dollars
to upgrade its bathroom amenities
when an amenity shows up in an amenity
war it doesn't always get accepted and
stick around in the 60s the battles were
fought over color televisions remote
controls and Clark radios and those are
here to stay but the sewing kits and
shoe horns of the 70s are relics of the
era even the minibar rising to
prominence in the 90s is being phased
out for the most part hotels choose
amenities they think will provide a
feeling of luxury at a low cost to the
hotel so they don't necessarily go for
the stuff you expect to have at home
sometimes in the race to set themselves
apart hotels introduce amenities that
border on the absurd wax for ceiling
letters cowboy hats and bandanas cats
that can visit your room video cameras
dictionaries in room exercise bikes and
rare books have all made an appearance
as amenities over the years and while
these things might seem like nice free
bonuses for guests it's important to
remember that you're paying for the cost
of the amenities somewhere the $15 worth
of soaps and coffee might be subsidized
by the $30 a night parking fee and
amenities can generate a massive amount
of waste hotels and travelers combined
throw out as many as 5 million used bars
of soap a day charity organizations like
clean the world are working to recycle
as much of this as possible
providing soap to places that need it
but currently only 20% of US hotels are
involved meaning the large majority of
soap is still being thrown away so when
can we expect the next amenity war we
might be on the brink of one at the
moment this year
localized skirmishes have erupted in
Nashville Tennessee leading to chef
prepared meals for pets your choice of a
buckwheat goose down or latex pillow and
recording studios all being offered as
amenities at various hotels in the area
and maybe the most interesting amenity
I've ever
come across humans in 2016
Weston started it's running concierge
program in an effort to bring local
runners around the hotel to provide a
more local atmosphere for the guests who
like to run ultimately hotel amenities
are a great case study for how
competition in a market can generate
both useful progress that benefits the
customer and ridiculous features that
will tell tale of around campfires for
generations thanks to Squarespace for
sponsoring this video
Squarespace is hands-down the best and
easiest way to build a website for your
hotel cat movie or YouTube channel I've
used Squarespace for a long time and I
just added a recommendations page to my
website
Thomas flight comm using Squarespace it
was easy to add books movies music and
YouTube videos to page in a way that
looks good no plugins or updates are
required ever if you want to check out
that page and see some of the things I
think are cool I'll link to it in the
description and you can start your free
trial today at squarespace.com
Thomas flight and use code Thomas flight
to get 10% off your first purchase or
use the link in the description below at
squarespace.com / thomas flight get
started building your website today
thanks so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed this video special thank you as
always to my patreon supporters go to
patreon.com/scishow on a slate for more
information and I'll talk to you again
next time